OK.
So that's the basic Wordle.
One other thing that I really
like about the real game
is that it shows a keyboard.
It shows a keyboard of
what letters you've used
and which ones that match.
So we can add something
like that really quick.
So I'm just going
to keep it simple
and make another
text output like this
and have that display the
keys that are remaining.
So let's do another
verbatim text output.
Call it keyboard.
And also I just realized
one other thing,
which is that we need
to give-- we should
give some indication what these
brackets and parentheses mean.
So we can do that
by writing some--
essentially just
writing some HTML.
This is like a P HTML tag.
So let's just say bracket means
that the letter is correct--
yeah, letter is correct.
I'll do that.
And another one.
So parentheses x means that
the letter is in the word
but in the wrong place.
OK.
So that should-- yeah, so save.
So now we've added that
information there and now we
can add a keyboard.
Just for the remaining letters.
So let's say output,
call it keyboard.
Let's do render text again.
And we need all the letters.
So i guess we'll just do
it the old fashioned way.
So letters equals.
And I think-- what's
the best way to do this?
Let's just do paste.
Q. All right.
So I'm making enough
space around these letters
to put a bracket around it
Oh, do we need to do that?
I don't need to
do that right now,
but I'm going to do it anyway.
And then this is going to be
shifted over a little bit.
All right.
And one more.
OK.
So those are our letters.
That's our keyboard.
And we're going to use a new
line between each of those.
OK.
Actually, let me call this keys.
And so what I'm going to
do here is really basic.
I'm just going to do
a search and replace.
So what I need to do is take the
letters from all of the guesses
and I need to check if each
one is in the keyboard.
I'm doing this in a
really simple way.
I'm not going to
indicate on the keyboard
which letters are correct or
that you used and were correct
and which ones were not
correct and not in the word.
That's how the real
Wordle game works.
In this case, I'm
just going to indicate
which letters you've used up
in which ones are remaining.
And that's really easy.
So I can just take
all of the guesses.
I can say-- let's see.
Used letters is-- first let's--
yeah.
Let's paste together all of
the words and all guesses.
All guesses collapse
equals that.
And then we can split that
into your character vector.
Again, doing this string split
and then bracket one again
like we did it before.
And then we can say
used letters is unique.
Put unique elements in that.
All right.
So let's just try
this at the console.
Let's just assign
something to all guesses.
Let's say this is first, second.
Let's just say those
were our guesses.
And then we can
step through here.
So the used letters is those
two words stuck together.
Then we split it into
the individual letters.
And then we take the
unique ones out of there.
So we should not
see, in this case,
there's two S's and we should
see one of those disappear.
OK.
So these are all the letters
that we've used so far.
And we just need to remove
those from this keyboard.
We'll just use that.
We'll do that using
a regular expression.
So that should be--
that's really easy.
So let's say for letter in
used letter and used letters.
Actually let me just say letter.
That's a little bit simpler.
Keys is.
And we'll do-- we'll use
sub to replace letter.
Oops, not in quotes.
Variable letter with
an empty string.
And that's in keys.
And at the end,
let's return keys.
OK.
All right.
Let's see if it works.
There's our keyboard.
And that's great.
So let's say aisle.
It did not do anything.
So that-- [LAUGHS]
oh, you know why?
OK, here's the problem.
So this didn't work, and
that's because all guesses,
this render text happened
once, but there's nothing
because this is a
reactive object.
And there's nothing that's
triggering the reactivity
to re-execute because all guess
is just a regular variable.
It's not a reactive one.
So if we want
changes to this all
guesses variable to trigger
this render text to change again
or to re-execute and then
update which keys are available.
So there's sort of the
correct way of doing it
and then there's the
sort of-- there's
a hacky shortcut we could use.
And the hacky
shortcut we could use
is to have it listen
to this Go button.
But sort of the
correct thing to do
is to look for changes
to the all guesses vector
and re-execute
when that changes.
So let's make all
guesses a reactive val.
Reactive val which
has the starting value
of an empty character string.
And we need to update it here.
I'm going to split this
into two lines just
to make it a little
clearer what's going on.
So all guesses new is that.
But because this
is reactive now,
we need to invoke
it like a function
to get the existing
value out of it.
We can't just access it
without the parentheses.
So we're going to take the
existing value for all guesses,
append the new guess
onto it, and we're
going to save it in this
local variable called
all guesses new.
And then we need to assign
it back into all guesses.
And the way we do
that is all guesses,
parentheses, all guesses new.
That should assign it back.
And then when we
use it down here,
we'll just invoke
it like a function.
And because we're using this
reactive val from this render
text, every time
this thing changes,
the value here changes, it
will cause the render text
to execute.
So let's try this again.
Aisle.
Go.
That totally did not work.
Error in compare words.
Oh, yeah.
Here we go.
We need to call a
function there as well.
All right.
Reload.
Aisle.
All right.
And then saves.
Great.
As you can see, it's taken
the keys out of here.
And gives.
And that's working correctly.
Now, there's one thing
I want to mention
about using the reactive val,
which is that one thing that's
happening here when
we call all guesses
is that normally when we
do this, because this is
a reactive val, this
render text will take
a dependency on all guesses.
So whenever all guesses
changes, it would re-execute.
So if you do this in many
cases, what can happen
is you end up in this
sort of reactivity loop
where you keep
appending something.
You keep appending something
to all guesses and then
that causes render
text to re-execute
and then it grows it
again and it keeps
going over and over again.
We happen to not have that
problem here because we're
using the bind event.
So the only thing that
will cause this render
text to re-execute is when the
input Go button is pressed.
And so when you do this bind
event on the render text
or on a reactive or
observer, it makes it
so that it doesn't listen
for changes to the reactive
and validations of
things that are inside
of this block of code.
So we're lucky in
this case that we
don't have to worry about
that sort of infinite loop
happening.
If we did, if we weren't
using the bind event
and we're just using a render
text by itself the normal way,
then we could use a
function called isolate.
So we could say isolate.
And then that would
cause this render text
to not take a
reactive dependency
on that reactive val.
And we would have to
do it here and here.
But we don't have to because
we're using bind event.
So here we go.
Yeah, this is our
basic Wordle game.
I mean, this is the
basics of the game
and you can waste a
lot of time playing it.
I already have.
[LAUGHS]